freedom is different things to different
people what do you think freedom is
[Music]
dear slaw Paul de Leeuw betta em
but I feel of its own oxygen freedom I
don't know who was attempting bullets na
la libertad me is so I'll see Ali
effective a billion per year so doctors
men and the British service see the
Buddhist good to see you doing all of
that should be bosco medina schemata
banter
so what the total stress tracker really
[Music]
to family
do you fish it does today cameras many
nebraska's to my clinic in Omaha police
moves freedom it's the power to pay
their own existence in this world the
rupees is not to be
I was lucky on a telephone know me that
being happy in your own skin can be
extremely liberating palermo paris see
out the other when you do your trick how
a diode is sauna legacy also both the
young Amelia techinical say the freedom
is lies
Oh freedom is everything Bravo
vamos systems O'Meara Bravo
not working going to the beach muscle
bother you be less I'm okay with him
elacry I'll come up with a co-ed mr.
mind counting power hi Daddy roba so
Mariela was happening
swap what they did abortion so bother it
shows Oh take my machine turn back to
hunter think about that
freedom what is freedom
you
[Music]
[Music]